thanks james
okay so i'll talk about uh efficient
parallel solver for sdd linear systems
at least that's what that's what i
thought i would talk about when i send
in the title and abstract turns out
there that turns out this can be an
entire class of algorithms there are
several variations that showed up in the
meanwhile and quite a bit of it is
drawing work with some
some people here in the room so this is
drawing work this this represents some
joint work with the hachen
yuchen inte region is over there intact
lee
yan liu dan spielman and john hartun
so the talk is structured as follows
i'll start by describing the problem so
the lx equal to b problem describe what
makes it difficult
then i will describe our key tool
and how to use these tools to get
parallel solvers
as well as
other representations of the inverse of
the graphic plasma matrix
so the problem is motivated by large
graphs specifically that i have
i have large graphs showing up in many
in many real data sets for example
images i take pixels these are my
vertices
road networks junctions are
vertices social networks everybody's a
vertex
friendships are edges and measures where
uh the space is discretized into a into
a point set
so some of these graphs get really large
so they have anywhere between say 10 to
the 6 to 10 to the 12 vertices and edges
so it makes them challenging some of
them challenging to even store
but once we have them stored next
question is how do we analyze and how do
we compute over how we optimize though
so here are useful definitions for
representing graphs and for
analyzing them is a graph of plastic
which is which is a central object in
spectral graph theory
this is
build a matrix where every row and
column
corresponds to a vertex
so this corresponds means that my
off-diagonal entries can be interpreted
as values between pairs of vertices
so every off-diagonal entry i can just i
can set that equal to the negation of
the edge weight
and then i put the degree of the graph
on the diagonal so my diagonal equals
the weighted degree
so by this construction because i put
the negation on the weight
this means that my row and column sums
is zero also because i'm dealing with
undirected graphs i will assume this
this is a symmetric graph
so in this example over here this edge
of weight two
corresponds to this entry of negative
two on the off-diagonal energy
so once i have the graph
laplacian the natural thing to do is to
solve a linear system in it
so this is uh the l x equal to b problem
give my graph laplacian l vector b find
vector x such that l x is approximately
b
and to to describe efficiency i will
assume that it's m by n matrix with m
non-zero entries so n is number of
vertices or dimension m is the number of
non-zeros and edges
so this operation of lx equal to b
in the in the last 10 years there has
been a
there has been many beautiful
applications of this uh primitive and
this has led to what's known as the
laplacian paradigm
so if you just solve a graphoplasty or
precondition with a graphic plus this is
directly connected to what's known as
elliptic method of elliptic problems in
numerical analysis and scientific
computing
it lets you solve for problems such as
such as a
problem such as heat equation or
differential equations such as using
collision modeling you can embed planar
graphs with them
once you iterate with a solver you can
compute objects such as eigenvectors or
heat kernel of the matrix
so this is used in a lot of applications
such as spectral
as as spectral segmentation
finding sparses cut balance cuts and so
on
if you take a solvent iterate more times
with it so once you iterate it or say
polynomial in n number of times
you can start you get solutions to many
classical graph problems as well as
problems from image process
so examples include image segmentation
which is actually related to the
sparse's cut problem here
you can also use it to generate random
spanning trees
compute max flow max weight matching
as well as a variety of other graph
problems
so the
so because of the partly because of
these applications
there's been a lot of attention given to
the
the question that's to the to this core
primitive in the laplacian paradigm
which is how fast can i compute lx equal
to b how fast can i solve this
so because this is just a
a linear system so i can apply
off-the-shelf tools such as
well such as gauss elimination or that
with otherwise known direct message to
it
these methods running about n-cube time
there has been a lot of
work in this area giving run time as
approximately 2.3727
so once again to describe running time i
will say n is an n by n matrix with m
non-zero entries
you can also use iterative methods
so if you believe in exact arithmetic
these iterative methods you can show
that they run time as n times m so
number of dimension times number of
non-zeros
if on the other hand if you believe in
round off errors the more popular bound
is m times square root kappa where kappa
is the condition number of the matrix
so these are methods that
work for any linear system
but because we're dealing with graph
laplacians
we can also use the fact it's a graph
and
make gains through the this graph
theoretic connection
so this is this led to our area known as
combinatorial precondition
the first resultant on this up in this
direction was by vijay who gave an
algorithm ranging about m to the seventh
fourth time and then there were many
subsequent improvements so bowman and
hendrickson slow you can get to n times
m
let's feel my intention first that you
can get to a m to the one point three
one running time
and subsequently to about m polylog n so
this is the what we call this filament
and solver
and then there were subsequent
improvements in the last five years
that greatly improved the running time
of this type of method
i think so i think most of the authors
on these sequence of results are in the
room here so
so basically at some point everyone
decided that hey we should make the
solvers go faster
and they got running times as a form of
m log squared in
m log n
m log to the 1.5 n using a different
method
and then eventually to m square root log
n with with a few log log factors in
there
so it's fair to say that in the
sequential setting
we have
we have fairly good ideas to solve these
linear systems
but then there's a question of how do we
how do we start implementing some of
these
and a very important aspect of modern
architecture is that there's a great
deal a great amount of parallels
so what so while the
so so i was in grad school the machine
on my desktop that had eight cores
and software like matlab they implicitly
use these parallels which is why so if
you look at the current solver package
by giannis it talks with matlab it's
because it's
it's because matlab
for certain routines matlab is able to
take advantage of this kind of
parallelism
and get speed up that way
so the common architectures that have
parallelism include multi-core
architecture mapreduce that's data
centers
and the general idea is that if i have
multiple cpus i can just split work or
have multiple machines i can reduce my
work by splitting it among the machines
so of course the total amount of work
doesn't decrease so that's the notion of
work
but the limit which you can split up the
parallel computation
is limited by the number maximum number
of dependent steps so this is known as
parallel time or parallel depth
and it turns out that for
for these nearly linear work
laplacian solvers
one can get algorithms are paralyzed
so the first result on this direction
was by janis and gary they gave argument
ranging about n to the one point
n to the one sixth time for planar graph
for general graphs uh
the bladlock al showed that it's
possible to get to a depth of roughly m
to the one third
and i look and i will come back to this
in a moment these there are some
inherent bottlenecks in these methods
so what we show in this result
is that we can get solvers that run
nearly linear work and poly log depth
so we get depth that's that's poly log n
times polynomial kappa
and the times other log factors
so one thing that i'm
i'm omitting here is that uh i'm
generating a linear operator that
approximates the inverse even though the
graph of the plot so the graph of plus
itself is actually low rank so it has a
null space with the r1s vector
i will just i will hide this under the
rug i will just use inverse throughout
the the talk
so there's several ways of dealing with
this one's just like slightly bump up
one of the entries on the diagonal to
make it full rank and just just claim
numerical convergence
so the other details in this is that um
my dependency on the error
so this dependency on epsilon it's log
one over epsilon so this means that the
solver converges
very quickly to the exact answer so this
may may as well be exact so
the other difference is that i have a
dependency on log cap
so there is a dependency on the
condition number of matrix so this
algorithm is numerical in nature
but usually we can also assume that
kappa is somewhere on the poly poly end
range
and that's because you can show that
kappa is less or equal to the max weight
divided by the minimum weight in the
graph time polygon factors
so if you assume your edge weights are
have reasonable
spread you can also assume that this is
poly essentially a polylog depth
algorithm
we also give extensions in that this
this routine also generalizes to taking
piece powers of the matrix for nap
between negative one and one
so you can
extend this algorithm to other matrix
functionals as well
so
in this talk i would like to
solve the problem l x equal to b in
polylog depth and nearly linear work
and let me just describe what makes this
problem difficult
so one way to see the difficulty of
a linear system solving graph laplacians
as well as just graph organs in general
is by considering these two extreme
instances
on the left is a highly connected graph
you can think about as a complete graph
except it's not as nice as a complete
graph say a random graph with about
analog and edges
this is often known as expander
it's a highly connected graph
if you make any kind of local step it's
going to get expensive very quickly
so if you start doing say partial doing
also elimination quickly you just get a
very dense graph that's expensive so the
way that these things are usually solved
is with global steps
on the other hand
you can get long paths or trees
so these are things with a very high
diameter
so for these kind of graphs to get one
end of the graph to talk to the other
you need to propagate information
diameter times and diameter can be as
big as n
so you need many steps so each of these
steps better be inexpensive
each of these is easy on their own
iterative methods are designed to handle
this kind of density kinetic case
and combinatorial methods are gauss
elimination they're designed to handle
this kind of long path scenario
and the main difficulty
in designing solvers for graphical
classes as well as solvers in general is
that i can give you a graph
that consists of a bunch of these cases
stacked on top of each other i can take
a bunch of expanders connect them
together with long path i can throw
another expander on top that's just not
as heavy i can just add graphs on top of
graphs
and
the solver algorithm needs to be able to
take
care of both of these cases
simultaneously
and you don't want to multiply the cost
of a global step times the number of
steps you need to address one of these
local problems
and
and this is the kind of difficulty of
most solvers you either need to look
into the structure of the graph pull out
these pieces
or you need to devise methods that
somehow work well for both of these
methods simultaneously well for both of
these classes of graphs simultaneously
and this is what the combinatorial
pre-conditioning framework was designed
to do
and and all the previous fast algorithms
all the nearly linear time solver
algorithms fall into this class
what this type of algorithm do is that
they reduce the problem into three
pieces so to special specification
tree contraction and iterative methods
special specification in turn you use
tree based routing
low stretch spanning tree for finding
the tree and local partitioning for
doing for setting up a sparsification
routine
the general idea of this framework
is that i want to repeatedly reduce my
graph
to sparser graphs
so what i do is i take a graph i find
this graph that's faster than it that's
similar to it
recurs on it
and recurs all the way until my graph
because it's easy so by easy in this
framework it means a tree
tree is nice because i can just do gauss
elimination on it and it will disappear
and i can do tree contraction in the
middle of the algorithm
so this is the recursive preconditioning
framework
and
the focus of pretty much every single
result since vita has been improving
this
this part of the spectral specification
routine
well this part of the framework which is
a spectral specification
what we think about is that we're
finding better and better
specifiers that we can plug into this
framework
on the other hand
the driver routine
which is repeated gauss elimination plus
iterative method
that has stayed more or less the same in
the in the last 25 years
and one way to think about this driver
code
is that once you unroll all the
recursion once you unroll all those the
cost savings
what is really doing is generating a
polynomial
in lg lt inverse so generating a
polynomial in a graph pre-conditioned by
the final tree
and what we're trying to generate we're
just trying to generate the inverse of
this operator so we have the graph times
the tree inverse we want to go from that
to the tree times the graph inverse
and because it's a polynomial
all these methods what they can be
viewed as is that they generate this
polynomial and then they go about
evaluating
and the evaluation scheme is not too
different than horner's method which
just says that i take my terms multiply
by the coefficient
add another constant term repeat
so
with a degree d polynomial
where each term corresponds to a matrix
vector multiplication
to get to evaluate one of these degree d
polynomials horner's method takes about
d log and steps
and in the film and 10 framework
and pretty much all the subsequent ones
we get that the degree of the polynomial
is roughly square root of n
and the only reason these routines get
faster speed ups is because
they do this step so well that when
combined with
the size reductions my intermediate
graphs are able to be sparse to be are
extremely sparse and that's how i get
the runtime savings
so let me just expand on this part of
this notion polynomial approximation a
little more
so polynomial approximation is one of
the ideas under that underlies numerical
numerical methods
what it's trying to do is it's trying to
basically do division with
multiplication
and the simplest form of division with
multiplication is this power series here
so i want to evaluate 1 minus a inverse
the way that i can evaluate that is by
just taking some terms of this power
series 1 plus a plus a squared and so on
you know we know that when we sum this
to 2
we sum up this infinite series we get 1
over 1 minus 8.
and what we can show is because we're
powering a
these terms get smaller if a is between
negative one and one if a is strictly
between negative one and one
these terms
they
they just decrease decreasing size
so you feel that
that alpha is lesser the magnitude of
alpha is less than one
so we can there's notion condition
number which can just be defined as one
minus the max the max the magnitude of
eight
this is analogous to the spectral gap
and you can show that kappa terms gives
good convergence
and because of the spectral theorem
which says that symmetric matrices can
be viewed as destroying operators on
their eigen spaces
you can just extend this to work for
matrices so this is the reason we often
talk about spectral gap spectral gap is
just one minus the maximum eigenvalue of
the normalized random walk matrix which
is just a
we can do slightly better so this one
converges in kappa steps there is a
method known as chebyshev method we also
it was also described as heavy ball
method in the previous workshop
what it says is that a degree of square
root kappa is sufficient
so this is a part of a chebyshev
polynomial these are fairly intricate
objects
and what they say is that if i have
condition number kappa
i need a roughly a degree square root
kappa polynomial
and this actually is optimal up to
constant factors this is a well-known
result in functional analysis for the
setting of the solving linear system
there's a very nice proof of it in a
paper by hurricane secretary vishnu that
i highly encourage you to take a look at
so this this is roughly optimum
and what we can also show is that for
our definition of a tree so you just
restrict your definition of tree to say
a spanning tree
there exists graphs
where the
where the condition number of the graph
versus any tree
needs to be at least roughly n
so if you combine this
with the optimality
of chebyshev polynomials
a conclusion that
that's very tempting to draw is are we
looking at a square root and lower bound
in terms of parallel depth for these
kind of methods
and you might recall from earlier that i
mentioned a depth of n to the one third
so that's clearly not the case
so the question is what
what is going on in the bladlock al
result that gets around this lower bound
and this is actually a very simple fact
which is just matrices have inverses
if i compute u the inverse of my graph
laplacian i can multiply my vector b by
that inverse
in log depth but my work is fairly big
but my depth is
so formally
you can invert a matrix in n to the
omega
slightly more than enter the omega work
polylog depth
you can multiply once you have that
inverse you can solve linear systems in
it
in log depth and
and squared work
so the issue with these methods is that
these steps are expensive so the actual
work of invoking them expensive but
these are highly parallel methods and
this is why
a lot of
a lot of linear algebra problems if you
a lot of linear algebra problems are
easy to parallelize if we are okay we
say n cubed work
and the the reason that uh this
m to the one third where this amplitude
one third comes about in a blah blah
blah result
is that because this is so expensive we
can only use it for fairly small size
systems so it switches over to these
inverses at a size of roughly n to the
one third
and then gets the runtime too and then
we can show the runtime trades off to
that
so one way to improve over this kind of
parallel solver
is that if we're able to generate a
sparse representation of the inverse of
the graph of plasma
then we will get a faster overlap
so the question is can we have a sparse
approximation to the inverse of the
graph laplacian
and in some cases the answer is yes
so the nested dissection algorithm this
is start
this originated this was first studied
on square mesh by alan george and then
it was extended to general separable
graph planar graph by living rose and
target
and this is also the reason that so
using this kind of inverse we have to
get further gains so this is the result
by jonathan gary that got to m to the
one sixth step
so what we showed here is that uh the
standard numerical methods for solving
these linear systems so the standard
driver code that has certain limitations
and the question of getting a parallel
solver is more like more or less i came
to question of can we have a good
special representation of the inverse of
a matrix
there's one side that i should mention
is that the recent works on cut
approximating
cut approximation and i believe it's
routing
so these these were based on the
combinatorial preconditioning framework
and they can actually this would be
these ones paralyzed very naturally
and this is by madre sherman uh counter
lee urbica and sedford
and one and so these methods can be
viewed as as
there is a way to view them as
parallelizing uh the recursive
pre-conditioning framework through
asynchronous iterative methods
so this is fairly different than what i
what i will talk about i so here that
here there's another series there's
actually it's fairly different than what
i plan to talk about and also the the
trade-offs the parameters there are
other trade-off issues that show up
there
so maybe we can just
so i can i'll talk more about that that
connection later on
but in the meanwhile i'll describe our
key tool
so the
main so the motivating question for our
key tool is that
if i want to evaluate a degree d
polynomial
do i necessarily need depth d so the
question is is horner's method optimal
for evaluating a polynomial
and for those of you who are familiar
with the
repeated squaring the answer is no
so for example if i want to take a
number to the 16th power
what i can do is i can square it square
it again square it again square it again
just square four times
so repeated squaring already gives a way
to work around the lower bound and this
is the fact that i will
that i will build upon
in the next one
so this can also be applied to the to
the power method expansion earlier
so for the power series of one plus a
of sums of all the powers of a
you could represent that as uh one plus
a
times one plus a squared plus one one
plus a to the fourth and so on you just
take a bunch of products
involving powers of 2 out of 8 taken to
powers of 2.
of course this has a matrix version as
well
each of these terms instead of
little a to the power of 2 to the i i
can take a matrix to the power of 2 to
the i
but before i continue i need to talk
about how can i get into a situation
where my matrix a behaves like a like a
number between negative 1 and 1.
so this is the reduction that i will use
so i have a graph laplacian
i can add
self loops to my vertices to make all
the vertices have the same degree
so so i can transform into a regular
graph
and once i have a regular graph i can
just scale down the laplacian by its
degree
so i get identity
minus some adjacency matrix
so this makes my graph look like i minus
a
to make it full rank
what i'm going to do is i'm just going
to slightly scale down this matrix
so you're going to slightly scale down
the the edge weights you can show that
numerically if you do this with two up
to something like machine epsilon
it does not affect the answer too much
of course machine gaps not not a value
everyone is seeing a numerical algorithm
but this is just as a proof tool
and there are ways of sorting this out
but what this lets us assume
it lets us assume that a is a
is a weighted graph with where the
weighted degree at every vertex is at
most one
so this can be viewed so it can be
viewed as a transition
matrix for a random walk a lossy random
walk
so my expect the spectral norm of my
matrix is at most one so this is how i
can reduce my problem
to the case where it's more or less
behaves like a number between negative
one and one
and once i have this interpretation i
can start interpreting this kind of
factorization
so because a is the transition
probability of a random walk matrix a
squared is just two steps of my random
walk
a to the fourth fourth fourth steps of
my random walk
in general a to the 2 to the i
is true to the i steps of my random walk
so this view
this factorization
it can be viewed as computing a
stationary distribution of a random walk
by taking one step in each power each in
in in successive powers successive
squares of my random walk matrix so i
take one step of
of the two-step random walk matrix one
step in a four-step random walk matrix
one step in the eight step random walk
matrix and so on
and i just do this until my
my power random walk matrix gradually
disappears it comes in some sense
expanded it's rapidly mixing
and for this to happen
because i'm repeatedly squaring my
matrix and because earlier that i just i
said that it takes about half a step for
my random walk to mix
and i'm repeatedly squaring i just need
to set two to the i to kappa
so my the number of steps i will need is
just log cap matrix of multiplications
just to for me to simulate this kind of
random block
the issue though is that because i'm
starting square matrices these things
become very dense squaring is one of the
one of the big taboos in numerical
methods because you quickly generate
these very dense matrices
so the work just with this method
naively is going to be n to the omega
times polylog factors
and what we're going to show next is
that this mixes fairly nicely with size
reductions
so this kind of method
as an algorithm tool actually shows up
quite often in theoretical theoretical
algorithms
well it actually shows up in a variety
of places one of which is the
multi-scale methods which were described
in the talk on wednesday that was also
based on squaring of the matrix
i'm still trying to understand the
connections and if you know having
another connection better i'll be very
happy to discuss with with you about it
the other
the other one that looks similar to it
are the poly are the lock that's album
for shortest path this is based on
repeatedly doing the mean squaring of
the matrix so repeatedly take
take the
repeated compute two hops for this path
distance
the routines that look closest to what
we're doing are actually the log space
connectivity algorithms so this is this
is the algorithm by wrangle that says
that in log log space i can compute
whether two vertices is connected in an
undirected graph
and in fact there's actually a direct
variant of it known as deterministic
squaring by rosman and vadan
that look almost exactly like the kind
of operation i'm doing here
so what they do
is that repeatedly they they repeatedly
square the adjacency matrix
until the spectral norm of the of the
matrix is small
and every step they take their graph
they reduce it to a low degree graph by
the use of expanders
they use a randomized method and what
they want to maintain is connectivity in
a graph
what we do instead
is that we do the same kind of iteration
step we do squaring we stop when the
special norm is small
but every step instead of doing just
maintain the degree to be small we just
make sure the graph is sparse so we
maintain the average degree to be small
we use a randomized method as well
but
the our requirement is stronger in that
we want to maintain solutions to i minus
a equal ax equal to b
so
this is our way of getting around the
lower bound described earlier which is
by just repeating squared
and in the next in the rest of the talk
i'll describe how to translate this into
algorithms
so before we describe algorithm let me
first launch the philosophical session
of what is a numerical output
so i have a routine that takes the input
b
outputs a vector x
and for many numerical algorithms if you
look at the inner loops of your
algorithm it actually does not have
it does not have if statements
it has a flavor of perform these
operations on a vector
add some values together sum a bunch of
things together output the answer
so these all these operations can be
viewed as linear transforms of course
this is under exact arithmetic but then
for the numerical round off errors you
can do the same kind of calculation as
well
so because we have a linear operator z
what we can do is just write down write
it down as a matrix
so i claim that most numerical
algorithms can be viewed
as corresponding to a matrix and we're
just doing a matrix vector multiply
involving b
and our goal is to create a matrix z
that is approximately the inverse of my
matrix
so
this notion of approximation
is going to be very important in
designing these kinds of algorithms
it's spectral similarity there are
several ways to think about it one way
is to think about it as the eigenvalues
of the the generalized eigenvalue
between the two operators
another way to think about it is through
luminar ordering which is this positive
semi-definite ordering amount matrices
but for this talk all i need to use is
that they obey all nice notions of that
you would expect from a similarity
operator
in that it obeys symmetricness so if a
similar to b b is similar to a it's
invertible so if a is similar to b a
inverse and b inverse are similar
and it's composable so a similar to b
with error epsilon b is similar to c
with error epsilon
a is similar to c with error two epsilon
that's all that's all i will use
so our goal is to create this operator z
that is close to the inverse of my graph
laplacian
using the sum and product of a small
number of matrices
and the reason that this notion of
similarity is great for working with is
that there are results
that say that i can take any graph and
specify it
into one with about n over epsilon
squared edges
so this is for any dense graph
i can take it does not matter how many
edges i start with all it matters is the
vertex count and my error requirements
and my final graph size only depends
on the number of vertices and my error
prime so m over epsilon squared
of course we want to do this efficiently
right now well currently
if we want to do this efficiently we
need to pay a few logs uh in the both
the size of the output and the work so
this is a this actually was from the
original construction special specifiers
by spearman 10
and
if you combine that with subsequent
improvements namely a sdp-based uh
partition routine by oracle visionoid
you can you can get
efficient and parallel specification
routines
and of course there's also a few other
tricks that we need because we're
squaring the matrix as well
so this result is actually for any graph
laplacian but we can also check that if
we square the graphing plastic we can
still implicitly construct a specifier
very quickly
so
this result has already been improved by
kude by janus kudis who gave a faster
algorithm based on combinatorial
methods so this is based on spanners
or even just low diameter decompositions
but what we're going to do we're just
going to take this result and use it
so we're just going to apply this to our
matrix repeatedly over and over
so i start with with a
i create i minus a 1 that's similar to i
minus a squared
i create i minus a 2 similar to i minus
a 1 squared and so on i just create this
chain
so this is what i would call this the
approximate inverse chain what it does
is it takes a graph
puts in more edges but specifies it so
it makes the graph more connected
and then repeats so eventually you get
something that looks more like more or
less like the identity matrix so
eventually you get a graph that is
pretty much uniform
so we can show that because we're
squaring the matrix its condition number
will just decrease by a factor of two
but even and even if we introduce errors
as long as we keep our error reasonably
small so less and constant
this condition still holds
for a smaller value of two
so what we can show is that in about a
log kappa steps
the we do get to mixing even with these
approximations so this leads to a chain
of depth log cap
another question is just how do we use
this chain
so recall that we want to compute
a approximation to 1 minus a inverse
which is equal to these products
and the only condition that we have is
that we have that 1 minus a of i plus 1
is approximately the same as 1 minus a i
squared
so we don't have so our intermediate
condition doesn't even look like
the factorization we have we can't just
say like i plus a
i plus a is roughly the same as i plus a
squared so we can say i plus a2 is
roughly the same as i plus a squared
so what we do is we apply this kind of
condition gradually
we apply this one at a time to the
root
so the idea is that we use the
factorization of
of 1 minus a squared so we know that 1
minus a squared is 1 plus a times 1
minus a
so what we have is that we have that 1
minus a i inverse is roughly 1 plus a i
times 1 plus 1 minus a i squared inverse
and here
because we have that now that this is
similar to the next operator
we can substitute that in this if we're
working with scalars i'm doing something
horrible with matrices i will deal with
that on the next slide but assuming
we're dealing with scalars we can
substitute with the next operator just
because this similarity notation also
carries over under inverses
so this gives us a way to propagate
operators back up the chain
and we just do an induction
reverse back backwards of the chain
because we have that uh one minus a d is
close to the f to one okay we have
operator z d
that is similar to the inverse of my
last level operator
so by the inductive hypothesis i can
assume that i have an operator similar
to my next level so the operator z of i
plus one that is more or less the same
as the inverse of i minus
a i plus one
so what we do then is we just take this
and let that be our operator so we
substitute this
with our next level operator
and what we have is that because we have
that
our next operator is similar to the
inverse of the next level system i can
just
by similarity i can just pull this over
i can just replace that operator with
the with the exact inverse
and then by that identity above over
there so i buy this identity i get that
it's similar to the to the up to the
inverse of my current operator
so this gives me a way
to propagate inverses up the chain
through the use of operators
so this is for the scalar case
and in the major case in a matrix case
there's a big issue
which is that what i want to replace by
approximations
the terms around what i replaced needs
to be symmetric for me to claim that
that i can
the same kind of error guarantee carries
over
so if i want to replace z with z prime
that's similar to z
i need to have u and u transpose around
z so the part that around my expression
needs to be symmetric
another way to think about it is that
whatever operation i write around z
the term needs to read the same
backwards forwards and backwards
so this is sometimes using z of i plus 1
at most once
but the operation that i wrote down
earlier which is this i minus a i
squared
well this which is this i minus a i
of z plus z i plus 1.
that is not symmetric around the
operator it's clearly i have one term on
one side nothing on the other side
so the main
so once we have this set up
the main difficulty in the problem is
just come up with a symmetric
factorization
of i minus a
involving i minus a squared
and this is the factorization we use
so we so this is just by some algebra
manipulation you can get to an operation
to a factorization that happens to be
symmetric around the term involving one
minus a squared
you just put one term of one plus a on
each side
and you can show that just by by by
checking the identity that it is
this is actually a expression the right
expression
so of course this can be carried over to
the matrix setting
just by the spectral theorem again
because my matrix a commutes with
identity so i'm just working in just its
own eigenspace so i can just apply the i
can just apply spectral theorem to all
my item spaces
and what i get is i just use i invoke
this kind of identity in my induction
back up the chain
so my inductive hypothesis gives that my
z of i plus 1 is similar to my to the
inverse of my next level
and the construction of my chain
implies that this inverse is also
similar to the inverse of the current
level squared
so we just so if you compose these
together
you get that i have a good approximation
to the current operator squared
and all we need to do is just take this
approximation and substitute in for this
term
so once we perform the substitution you
just get this off this representation of
the inverse operator of my current level
and what the inductive hypothesis gives
you is that you get an error that's
slightly larger and just plug that error
in
so you get that i have a good inverse
operator of my current level as well
so every level of every level of
induction i gain an error of epsilon
so all i need to do is just to make sure
my total error buildup is not so big so
i set my error to be one over d whereas
d is the depth
so i get an error roughly log kappa of f
times epsilon
so the pseudo code of this algorithm
once you unroll the way that we're
substituting operators is also extremely
simple
the general idea is just i just proceed
once down the chain so i multiply by the
right side operator
and then i proceed again went back up
the chain on the left side
so all i'm doing is i just
compute a bunch of vectors that's
i plus a i times my current vector
last level i do nothing and just copy it
over because i'm going to use identity
as my inverse
and then i propagate these back up the
chain by just adding my current vector
plus some copy of the solution to the
next vector
so this leads to something that looks
extremely similar to the multi-grid
algorithm so it's a v-cycle-like
algorithm
and what we get is we get a solution
from matrix vector multiplications
involving log capacitive sparse matrices
so we get a depth of log kappa
so we need to set epsilon to roughly one
over
one over the depth before we do it for
the total error to be small
so the number of non-zeros at every
level is going to be m poly log n times
log squared cap
summing over the total side of the chain
because we have one of these matrices
per level
we get a total depth of roughly poly log
end and then a work although that's also
in poly log
so the the new idea that we introduced
here
is that we can keep all the intermediate
matrices sparse
and the way to analyze these algorithms
is by viewing every algorithm as its own
matrix
and just apply a spectral similarity
and propagate our propagate special
similarity between these operators
around in an inductive manner
so
this is where i thought this algorithm
stopped i thought it was kind of a
so
if you ask me this say four months ago i
would say this album is just a fairly
strange situation it's kind of a curious
it's a curious phenomenon but i didn't
think that this actually has extensions
and what motivated us to look for
extensions of this algorithm
is the problem of sampling from gaussian
graphical models
so here the idea is that i want to
sample from a gaussian
with covariance matrix i minus a
so so this is a phrase in this in the
computational statistics setting
but what formally what i need is i need
a matrix c such as c transpose c equals
the inverse
so if you're okay with num square
matrices there is a fairly easy way
using the factorization of my graph
laplacian to get this
but say we want to also have a symmetric
factorization so a square factorization
and the form of the if we just use our
earlier algorithm what we get is that
because we're adding an identity at
every level
what we're getting is we're getting a
sum of sum of products of matrices so it
doesn't have this kind of
factor it's not factorable in this sense
so what we want is just a product that
approximates inverse of my matrix
so here you are assuming the attractive
model like the only all the a is
positive entries
right so now that the general gaussian
graphical model can have both yeah so
this is assuming that my my covariance
matrix is happens to be a graphoplasty
this is a fairly this this is a
specialized class of graphical models
calcium
thanks okay
yeah so this this was a this was also
recently studied uh in the setting of
cad get gibbs gibbs method to to perform
well in parallel and this was also the
setting study there which is what
motivated us to look at this from this
perspective
and so the other way so suppose we just
want a product
so recall the factorization earlier of
just i minus a inverse is i plus a times
i minus a squared
inverse and recall that i just want a
factorization
that's the metric
so the even simpler way to factorize it
so it's a metric is just to instead of
having a full full power here
pull a half power over onto the other
side so these matrices all commute
because it's just a and identity the
same eigen space they all commute
so we can't get to this this set
but then the question is what happens so
and if we repeat this so if we
repeatedly substitute approximations to
the next operator
what we do get is we do just get a c
equal to the square root of a bunch of
matrices
so we could get such a factorization
but the problem is how do we evaluate
one half power of a matrix
this in general seems like an even
harder problem
but one thing that we do know is because
we know that a1 is the square of a0
we know that all the eigenvalues of a1
is between 0 and 1.
so if you look at all the eigenvalues of
i plus a1
we have that they're all between 1 and
2.
so this is numerical in the numerical
language is this is a very well
conditioned matrix
and for well-conditioned matrices
anything pretty much works
so you can take the taylor expansion of
the functional you want to evaluate this
well formally it's the maclaurian series
expansion
so you get that you can have a low
degree polynomial approximating
everything after the first term so all
the all these terms you have low degree
polynomials approximating
the problem still is what about the
first term we still need to take the
square root of the first term as well
and this is uh this is the third
solution that we can take for this
problem
so this is uh in in a recent
the recent result with a chain
with chan chan and
do
and
10. so the
so the idea is just instead of having uh
four
four copies of the matrix
take half of the matrix at every step
and turns out that the factorization
still gives inner terms that's easily
specifiable
and now because of the matrix of the
eigenvalue of each one of these matrices
is between negative one and one half of
the matrix is between negative half and
half
so all my terms are now very well
conditioned
so what we can do is we just use a log
log kappa degree taylor expansions of
all these terms substitute in
and we get a representation that is just
multiplied together a bunch of
low-degree polynomials
so that gives a representation
that is just a product of matrices
so this also has generalizations because
uh uh so so the the nice thing here is
that
what we can do is we can now try to uh
we can show that specification of this
term also preserves its p power operator
so if we want to compute a p power of a
matrix for some p between negative one
and one the same factorization will also
work just as putting a different power
in in these factorizations so in each of
each one of these taylor expansions
in each one of these maclaurin series
this so what this seems to suggest is
that this method leads to an entire
class of algorithms so it leads to a way
of factoring a graph laplacian
into a small number of well-conditioned
matrices
yeah just one question so so in this
setup why do you need the
bound and dominance conditions so i need
the condition because i want i minus a
square to be efficiently specifiable
nice yeah so the the the issue there is
for many classes of matrices
uh the square that has a higher has
bigger terms that's a little harder to
treat
but that does that is a very good
question and that i will talk about one
question next and that that's very high
up on my list of other questions
so this seems to suggest we can also
approximate a very wide class of
functionals
so this so i believe there is a lot of
open question that comes out of this
so
as you mentioned the question first
question is can we apply this to more
general classes of matrices all we need
is the square of the matrix to have a
good specified
sparse pattern for it
the sparse squaring seems to have a lot
of connections to a lot of iterative
methods we have an algorithm that looks
more or less like a multi-grid v cycle
so this seems to suggest that this that
has connections to iterative methods as
well as multi-level methods
so multi-scale decomposition of graphs
there were two talks on wednesday about
this and i'll be very interested in and
so i believe there's some very
interesting connections going on there
for other functionals we only looked at
p power matrices but it seems that for
other classes where if i have a function
that it can be represented as products
so if i have a function that i can apply
to products and i have
so if if i have two matrices that i want
to evaluate say the function of a times
b i can get it from a and b separately
that's a prime that probably should be
applicable so that this algorithm can
probably apply there
and
another question is that can the sparse
what kind of specification do we
actually need in this algorithm so we're
using structural specification
and we're using special specification in
a very strong manner
in that we're we need to have very small
error at every step because we're
chaining together about log kappa of
these errors
so
one question there for uh from a
theoretical perspective is what kind of
specification do we need when we compute
compose about log cap of these
specifiers
so to get this routine to be more
efficient actually running out of time
maybe take some of these open questions
offline all right okay it looks like
there's even another slide this one
doesn't end so
yeah there's a whole bunch of these and
uh okay
i can probably take some of these
offline and so some of them involve can
we get sparse fires to go faster and can
we start can we uh
and what parts of this routine is can be
can be implemented there actually quite
a bit of
some
quite quite a few subsets of the
routines used here are would already be
interesting have would already have
quite a bit of application consequences
as well
so that's all thank you
uh so in multi-grade diagonals there's
this interpretation that
what happens is that every level
in this recycle treats different parts
of the spectrum salts in different parts
of the spectrum
is there something similar going on here
it essentially addresses different
liking values different brackets
so
so the question is uh
there's this notion in multi-grade
algorithms that different parts of the
of the output addresses different parts
of the spectrum
so
so one thing i think one place where
it's helpful to look for this is in the
in the factorization so if you look at
the opening of factorized form so this
form of the factorization
every once a while i either identity
so you can ask yourself the question of
where
does this so for a single eigen space of
the solution where does it get fixed
and what you can show is that it gets
fixed roughly in so if my iron value is
kappa so if my special gap is like if
it's distance to the spectral gap it's
say like papa gets fixed roughly locked
up but steps in
so it gets fixed by this
plus i at roughly log half a level step
so you can interpret this routine as
fixing eigenspaces gradually
i'm not aware of algorithmic
consequences there probably are as well
i have one question does this mean you
get a sparsifier
you get a sparse so i give you some
graph and you get a sparse graph
such that this you know the laplacian or
the sparse graph to the minus one halves
is a good approximator for the boston of
the original graph to the minus one half
so the
so the question is given oh so the
question is
if i sparse if given given a graph
laplacian can i generate another graph
laplacian such that they are closed
under one half power this turns out to
be just a property of the luminal
ordering
so somewhat surprisingly this was a bit
surprising to me but it turns out that
if you have two graphs that approximate
each other in first power
they are half power so if any power
that's less than one with magnitude is
less than one they do approximate each
other
uh i meant the negative one-half power
oh yes
yes so if i have a graph of parsing
that's close to another graphoplasty
their inverses are also approximate each
other
and uh oh so you mean oh you mean
another graph of passing approximately
the negative one half of my first lone
pass i'll ask you in a sec let's uh
let's finish up